eric valère bonjour bonjour vous êtes
candidat aux élections législatives
vous vous présentez dans le centre sans
étiquette je vous attrape parce que
justement c'est l'occasion pour moi de
dire que je suis un homme de mission par
conséquent j'ai reçu une mission de mon
parti celui qui est présidée par
monsieur le président du conseil général
ancien est aussi ancien président la ctm
monsieur claude lise et donc le rdm je
suis investie par le rassemblement
démocratique pour la martinique mais je
suis aussi en mission parce que ça fait
dix ans que je préside les familles
martiniquaises c'est à dire en fait
c'est tout le mouvement familial je suis
déjà au parlement du des familles un nom
dans la société civile alors pourquoi
vous présentez-vous à ce scrutin alors
justement je vous disais que j'étais en
mission
on ne décide pas qu'on sera candidat
alors surtout lorsqu'on est dans un
parti politique le rdm a demandé les
camarades et le comité exécutif de
m'engager dans cette bataille électorale
parce que notre parti et porter
véritablement d'un patrimoine sur
l'évolution institutionnelle et sociale
de notre pays de notre territoire nous
sommes dans une période on va entendre
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de choses il
faut savoir que le rdm c'est un parti de
gauche et adn c'est un parti
démocratique c'est un parti qui a
soutenu jean luc mélenchon donc à
travers le programme de l'avenir en
commun et donc le candidat du rdr n'est
pas un électron libre et surtout dans ce
milieu très cacophonique alors donc ça
c'est une chose et puis cela fait dix
ans que nous sommes l'observatoire des
besoins des familles et nous sommes
porteurs d'un projet de politique
familiale à l'assemblée nationale on
discute chaque année d'une belle loi
c'est elle qui nous donne tous les
moyens de pouvoir faire évoluer la
société martiniquaise ne serait-ce
l'humanité des familles donc c'est la
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale voyez d'accéder au
haut niveau on y vient donc ce sera l'un
des projets prioritaires pour la
martinique si vous êtes et du hamas les
nationales eh bien oui un des projets
prioritaires je le dis tout le temps
c'est pour cela que d'ailleurs je reste
fidèle aux orientations de la venue en
commun le rdm également parce que je
pense que c'est par ce gouvernement là
c'est par cette majorité là que nous
allons pouvoir mettre en oeuvre ce que
jean luc mélenchon appelle de ses voeux
cette grande loi d'urgence sanitaire et
social et cela nous permettra
effectivement de corriger un certain
nombre de difficultés nous revenons de
deux ans où les martinique en était
maltraité un il faut bien le dire par
rapport à cette pandémie moi même dans
mon activité professionnelle j'ai
soutenu une plainte 1 parce que nous
avons estimé qu'ils avaient un déficit
de communication de préparation et quand
je vois ce que certains candidats qui
vilipendaient la population qui
ne comprenaient pas ce qui passe si ce
passé et bien je me suis dit non ce
n'est pas possible
pendant la crise le mouvement familial
que je préside était aux côtés des
familles quand il y a eu cette
déclaration de guerre il ya deux ans on
vous a dit la france est en guerre
couchez-vous et bien les familles ne
peuvent pas rester couché et c'est là je
pense que je fais la différence par
rapport à tous les autres candidats
parce que je suis dans le contre dans le
pragmatique mon adn c'est adn jeu
collectif et donc je suis missionnée
pour cela alors quels sont les projets
particuliers les priorités concernant la
circonscription le chante dans laquelle
vous vous présentez alors su où la
circonscription
je les dis je le redis c'est une
circonscription qui j'allais dire qui
concilie ruralité et urbanité
et puis c'est une circonscription qui
est doté d'une très belle façade
atlantique 1 c'est pour cela qu'on dit
centre atlantique quand on va sur le
françois
bien sûr le robert
quand on regarde le littoral à trinité
écouter ici un peu le lieu je pense de
villégiature le lieu où on peut
accueillir des activités touristiques
et puis c'est surtout le lieu de
production dans tout cas de on peut se
tourner vers on va dire la économie de
la mer y est d'ailleurs à trinité un
vieux une vieille école d'apprentissage
maritime et moi je vous dis vraiment
c'est une circonscription qui pour moi
offre des perspectives à long mois je
suis un homme de la ruralité même si mes
fonctions mais responsabilités font que
je suis dans ce milieu du haut bas
n'était mais nous savons bien que la
martinique profonde ne doit pas être
oubliée dans cette affaire j'ai choisi
mon camp un depuis mon jeune âge vous
savez je suis né dans le mouvement
associatif et donc
les électrices et les électeurs de la
circonscription centre atlantique la
première circonscription suis pas par
hasard que c'est la première et il y à
un centre d'intérêt qui est formidable
je suis porteur de ce projet là et puis
avec une garantie parce que c'est très
facile de vouloir être parlementaire
mais nous ne choisissons pas les bonnes
stratégies je crois que quand on est
électron libre on va aller faire
certains numéros nous avons déjà dépassé
le chrono bon bien que vous pouvez
est-ce que vous avez quelque chose à
rajouter à dire de particulier aux
électeurs alors ce que j'ai à des impôts
conclure parce que l'émission est très
courte je dois dire aux électeurs que à
l'assemblée nationale il faut faire
chauffer les choses il faut faire
chauffer la question de la réparation
jallet des eaux concrète
des dégâts liés au chlordécone
réparation humaine c'est à dire il faut
que le la protection sociale à
couverture assurance maladie de ces
personnes là soit assurée légaliser
c'est pour ça que j'ai parlé de la loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale il
faut de vrais moyens et puis la
réparation de notaire il faut dépolluer
chlordécone monsanto ces mêmes buts même
bagage
nous avons et c'est pas une dimension
seulement régional je veux dire il y a
des choix à faire soit on choisit
l'économie de marché et au choix soit on
choisit comme je lé fais comme le rdm le
fait on choisit de maîtriser l'évolution
de nos pays de notre territoire afin de
résoudre les réels problèmes de ce
territoire là et qui attendent depuis un
moment et puis je dirais je suis
je resterai eric valère merci
merci beaucoup